any sufficiently advanced technology
is in distinction from magic
want to talk about just your current
work and stuff that in the news lately
the james webb space telescope so talk
about that what did you investigate why
was it worth you know your considerable
valuable time and what was the ultimate
outcome of that right right so i i you
know if there's anything you know i
don't use the word hate a lot but
there's one thing i hate it's injustice
okay so i saw this article in the summer
of 2015 with the title should nasa name
observatories after bigots and
forbes.com
and i was like in shock i was like oh no
what you know and so i immediately did a
little google search to see what i could
find
and the only thing i could find was an
article that had been written five
months earlier by david savage in the
seattle newspaper where a reader had a
reader of his column had said hey i
looked at this james webb wikipedia page
and it looks like this dude was horrible
and they're naming the telescope after
him right
and so i'm like oh man it looks like it
might be true but still i don't really
see any real data so
let me go into this facebook group we
have called equity and inclusion in
astronomy and see what they think
and i go in there and sure enough it
looks like everybody accepts that this
is the case right and there was a call
in there people were saying someone
should confront nasa someone should
confront nasa so guess what i did in
2016. i took it straight to him
right not the top you don't always want
to go to the top because you go to the
top
you know where else is there yeah yeah
you got to go under the top right to
figure out what the situation is yeah
plan then determine whether or not you
go to the top
all right so i i
i approach an executive
um and approach the head of the
telescope
and neither had heard of these
allegations and they said look
give us everything you got and i gave
them everything i had and they said
all we see is accusations we don't see
any real data here would you mind um
looking at what happened so i'm like
sure i took it very seriously so i i
connected with the
librarians and archivists at nasa
headquarters who connected me with
people historians nasa historians and
people at johnson space center and
there's one guy who's doing a phd in
history on james webb uh at the
university of alabama in huntsville and
working at nasa marshall space flight
center
and none of them had heard of this stuff
okay so we're like wow but then they
started telling me about his behavior at
nasa in the 60s and they were just like
you know it looks like a completely
different guy and i'm like what the heck
is going on so you know there are very
specific allegations very specific he
said this thing in congress he made this
statement he led this effort he
initiated this effort so i work with
these historians and archives librarians
and we figured out
no he didn't it's a case of mistaken
identity everything that you say had
happened happened so there is a book
called this book right here towards
stonewall
on my shelf yeah so this book
is
for stonewall homosexuality and society
in the modern western world so in it and
in the wikipedia page
the author
says that oh the undersecretary of state
said this thing in congress
in uh
january 1950 january february
and so webb's title was under secretary
of state
but it turns out there were other people
with a very similar title
secretary of management under secretary
of administration right things like that
right so it wasn't webb who said it was
a guy named purifoy okay
and so then i said okay
clearly
he was not he didn't do exactly what
he's being accused of
but
what did happen
really at the state department
and
uh what did he do
if anything in this particular effort
and what did he do generally right and i
got the answers to all those questions
and i put it in the article okay so the
people who actually did this right so
this thing called the lavender scare is
real
all right so
here is how it
unfolds uh but anyway here here's what
happens
you know the phrase no good deed goes
unpunished so you know me and my small
team
we
uncover oh this is great it didn't
happen so here's how i think of it you
know how there's people wanting to pull
down confederate statues yeah
so imagine
there's these rumors of this person
they're horrible they you know murdered
slave enslaved people and did this and
the other did that and the other you
know and every african-american the
community who walks by it's like oh i
hate that thing right
then some white dude in the community
comes along and goes you know what i
researched that guy
turns out
he didn't do that
but not only that
he's done things that look like the
opposite of that wow
so
i
published this work
and some the small cobble of colleagues
and media are like oh but here's what
hakeem doesn't understand
are you familiar with the mott and
bailey logical fallacy
i probably committed it but no i don't
what is that
so here's what it is it has to do with
uh medieval
uh war so you have this um
courtyard you know your walls right and
so if a large army comes chances are
they'll make it through the wall into
the courtyard which is indefensible so
they would retreat
to the mott i think which was like a
tower on a hill and these things can be
impregnable right so the mott and bailey
logical fallacy is you go out on
something that doesn't make sense
right it's been proven false and so you
fall back to something that feels like
it's easier to defend but still treat it
like it's the first thing
right so um they're like oh he was in
charge
because
you know he was the under secretary of
state number two at the state department
he was running the state department
right and and if this happened in your
organization you are responsible
however
there is a lot of scholarship on this
and it's completely false and here's a
book about james webb and in here his
entire career is described okay and so
that is completely
not true that statement so anyway what
happens is i publish this article and
these
uh astronomers go on what can only be
called a disinformation campaign this is
after the 2021 article or
i wrote my article january 2021 yeah the
next day on the link tonight yeah yeah
they go into twitter you know they start
you know
saying oh you know it's a case of he's
complicit right now the word complicit
didn't show up before my article it was
like he led these things
contributable yeah yep right so now
you've done your martin bailey
switch okay the the important thing here
is that they held now a set of new
specific
um allegations and they are based
on the whole that i left in my article
all right and i will tell you what that
hole is there is a place in there where
i said
the only thing that ties webb to
uh these events is a memo from carlisle
humasin i don't know
what was the
reason that he gave him this memo it
appears to be to bring him up to date on
the situation of what they've been doing
but that's not what's important for this
article right now what's important is in
that article he gives the history of how
this whole thing unfolded
and so with these other sources that
i've used to show how it all unfolded it
tells a cohesive story
now
the very next day
a fifth person
outside of their group and you can see
this on there was an article written
uh the next day by one of the authors of
of the scientific american piece with
the title
the straights are here to save us
so i have two things to say about that
title number one
i've never publicly disclosed my
sexuality right
thank you for assigning me one yeah
i've seen you with your partners they
were women and i'm gonna say you call
yourself queer and i've hung out been
with there with you and your husband
like you know it doesn't show i could be
as you don't know what i am right but
you assigned me that you're assuming
right you're assuming right
and then the second thing is
damn straight i'm here to save you
because i noticed a long time ago
a trend
white people that were my friends would
come to me oh i came have you heard what
i heard dude yeah you would right and i
noticed hey when i hear somebody saying
some homophobia
it's usually in a room with
heterosexuals when i hear somebody being
misogynistic it's usually in a room of
men and so there was an event that
occurred where a male professor at my
university says something about our one
female professor and i didn't say
anything i just remained silent and i
knew that it was just
unjust and whatever right
and it bothered me so badly that i vowed
to myself that would never happen to you
i'm not going to be a safe space right
if you
want to bring your isms into my i'm
going to let you know
right now not here we're not rolling
like that right your your way of
thinking is not
the way we're doing things right so yeah
i am here to save you but anyway the
thing that they found that i did not
find in the book which is considered the
sort of like
uh you know authoritative source by
david k johnson called the lavender
scare he has a passage in there and it's
necessary to read it so here are the
actual memos from the webb truman
meeting that occurred in night on june
22 1950.
what happened is david k johnson
so he says under secretary of state
james webb met to discuss how the holy
committee and the white house
might quote unquote work together on the
homosexual investigation
truman told the undersecretary quote
he was sure we could find a proper basis
for cooperation unquote
and agreed that webb and two white house
aides should meet with hoey to establish
a modus operandi
that's how
he wrote it now let me tell you what you
get out of that number one they met for
the purpose
of discussing the holy committee
number two
this statement
uh work together in a homosexual
investigation establish a modus operandi
sounds like an open ended help us to
design how we're going to do this yeah
so first thing is
if you look at his at the articles they
put out and things they hold up this
meeting like he had a meeting with
truman we see that he had a meeting
we're trying to association right it's
guilt by association well what it is is
they're trying to say
you know it's like there's there's a
sound effect you know he had a meeting
with satan not say it's not truman
that's it's not guilt by association it
is that
it's a hot super high it's the highest
level right so he must have been
involved
but here's the thing
truman and webb met regularly
since 1946
webb ran an agency called the bureau of
budget
and he worked you know you ever heard of
this phrase economic indicators that
they used to
web invented that oh he was yeah at the
bureau of the budget and he and truman
were so close that truman told the
secretary of state dean atchison when he
got reelected we're putting webb in as
the second guy
at the department of state you don't
choose them i'm choosing them
webb was like what i don't have any
foreign policy experience he's like
that's not what you're there for webb
was what you would call like a
bureaucrat nerd right he's like in our
foreign relations we need some
organization and yada yada and this is
quoted in power and apollo so webb's job
was about foreign
relations and policy in a tough time
right now here's the other thing now
let's look at the actual what actually
happened at meeting they didn't meet to
discuss
the hawaii committee or anything like
that they had their regular meeting so
the first topic they discussed was
uh
charles spafford
and then then they discussed uh
what else did they discuss
general richard marshall
and they discussed the state of the
vogler case and then what happens
webb informs truman
by the way senator hoey
asked me to talk with him to bring a
message to you and have a meeting with
him so here's what it actually says
i informed the president
that senator hoey had wished me to find
out how the committee
and the executive branch
could work together on the homosexual
investigation
you see holy ass webb hey can you see
the victory workers on homosexual
investigation very different from truman
and webb conspired right quote unquote
right right right
and he the president
advised me to say to the senator
that he was sure we could find a proper
basis for cooperation
but we're not we still haven't talked
about what we're talking about
cooperating on right and his and this is
where he gets to it
he again president truman approved a
suggestion that mr murphy white house
counsel mr springarn the white house
liaison to the senate hoy committee and
i
see senator hoey
on saturday
not to discuss in modus operandi
to discuss
the necessary problems
involving this cooperation interesting
very different yeah
what are those problems
it's in every document even uh david k
johnson talks about the lavender scare
it's in the um
humor sign memo
at every turn
the senate was trying to get personnel
files of the people who had been
investigated for being a homosexual
all right and so the
executive branch was resisting turning
that over because it could be used a
political bludgeon
right right so let me tell you how
things actually unfolded because the
true
complicitness is with american society
so what happens is
john purifoy gives a senate tells
testimony
in
um
january of 1950
and
they're pressing him the senators on
people that have been kicked out of the
senate excuse me kicked out of the
department of state now this is after
they had a uh
is it i forget the guy's name blick or
something like that there's some person
who was turning over documents to the
soviets
that was in the state department of
state so it was sort of like oh we got
spies and there was a couple other spy
affairs right right context of the
moment
was really crazy so they're you know it
resulted in truman's 1947 loyalty order
but he like why would you why'd you keep
these people out purify resist resist
resist and didn't say they kicked them
out for quote-unquote being homosexuals
right
what happens next
public outcry from the conservative
parts of the nation
what this is what's in the state
department so politicians did what
politicians do there was already a
republican senator wary who who was
already pushing this going back that's
in the human sign memo but now
he does a new investigation to see if
they should have a committee and that's
talked about in the lavender scare
this congressional investigation
committee like the most recent example
of something like this is the benghazi
truck uh committees right something like
that it's a senate investigation state
department right so
they get their investigation
and
the guy who's leading the investigation
is a guy named flan is guy you know is
senator hoey so david k johnson record
that that quote someone is saying that
hoyt nearly fell out of his window it's
assorted affair i don't want any part of
it
um
and so what ends up happening is he i
want to get the exact same language
because basically what happens is is
that holy doesn't even run the holy
committee here's what it says
this is from
the the lavender scare as with many
congressional investigations the driving
force behind this hoy committee's
investigation of homosexuals was his
chief counsel francis flanagan hoey's
discomfort and ignorance regarding the
subject only increased flanagan's
responsibility
to the invest that the investigation was
handled behind closed doors further
enhanced his power
um
eliminating anyway
here's a flanagan quote i handled that
investigation planning and boasted when
later questioned about the homosexuals
and government inquiry flanigan managed
the research effort chose the witnesses
who would testify before the committee
and wrote the final report
right
flanagan would later remark if the
hearings had been public i'd have i'd
have made a worldwide reputation as a
great investigator of homosexuals
so the whole point here is
they try to place this meeting so what
happens is after
um
so
webb meets with truman
webb informs truman holy asks me to show
up
the way they write it is
the two white house folks go with webb
webb is the main guy going they're
coming with him that's not how it read
it says he approved a suggestion that mr
murphy mr springer and i attend this
meeting so they do
and there are these documents that come
out of it that say what they talked
about what do they talk about and by the
way david k johnson this last year
because of the disinformation campaign
has been quoted many times in the new
york times and other places and
webb was not a leader of this in any way
and there's even a um an interview you
get from 2004 online from uh uh
university of chicago press where he
goes you know completely through webb
hadn't absolutely nothing to do with
this now let's get back to this notion
that he was in charge he was in the the
line that come you know in the chain of
command and he did nothing
all right so let me tell you something
every year i would get an annual
evaluation
when i was a professor and i told you
that we had one woman in our department
and when i was in florida
i saw workplace misogyny like i had
never blatant like i i'd never seen
before in my life yeah all right so
every time i had an evaluation or if i
was in a meeting i was you know i
frequently had conversations with the
department head and the dean
they asked me what can i do better i
would say listen you are the leader the
leader determines the culture and
leaves the meeting it's up to you to
stop this and they always
you know
right
but i spoke out about this every chance
is there any record of me speaking out
against it there's no record of that no
no one would ever know right and here's
the thing you can't do you can't say yo
i got seven black friends right to to
show that you're not a racist you can't
say nobody
but there is proof
against
uh you know so so anyway
the point is
is that here is a quote from
uh powering apollo
here's what it says
it's titled losing influence at state so
basically the idea that i'm putting here
is that number one james webb was not in
charge of state department dean atchison
was and as number two you have only as
much power as number one
gives you the seeds yeah yeah yeah and
if you only have one job to do you know
that's the job you're doing so here's
what it says
um
because
anyway while he participated webb in
foreign policy discussions
represented the department at ceremonial
and social functions and made certain
decisions when atchison was out of town
he was for the most part a supporting
player webb
after his prominence and influence as
budget director webb found the
undersecretary's job constraining
as quote unquote number two
he had only the pieces of the action
atchison left him
and so it goes on to how he was into
science and technology and that's what
he went into but there's more right
so
um
there where he talked about atchison
style
uh oh but you know what there's another
statement in here
webb had spent
much time mending congressional fences
adept with legislatures
legislators he was the primary force at
state in getting funds for various
programs the department supported
even he however
could do little to affect the gathering
storm in congress over loyalty security
issues in the state department
webb was powerless
in the state department
he was pop he resigned his position
because he was powerless right so
what
um
uh
ends up happening is
here's another statement
about the relationship between webb and
atchison
all right so uh
webb was uh
looked at as being some sort of
philosopher king because he was all into
policy and bureaucracy and stuff
and so
here's the quote no philosopher king
would challenge atchison's judgments
webb's interest for organizational
purposes
meshed with atchison's for maintaining
his own role as the dominant policy
maker within the department
right yeah you know so they give like no
context at all
and
anyway let's get back to the holy sub
committee so what comes out of the holy
subcommittee so the one document that's
known
to history is a document that him or
sign gave to webb and humble sign is
definitely one of the
bad actors in this so as is purifoy as
is flanigan as is wary as is the
democratic senator hill from alabama who
joined with senator wary from republican
from nebraska to make it a bipartisan
congressional effort backed by the
american public the conservative
american public right so what happens
we're at a time where the korean war
starts the same week
right after that
right
and that's webb's only job is foreign
policy and he gets consumed by that but
he has to attend this meeting so he
attends this meeting
and the the readout is there it says
they talked about whether or not the the
hearings would be closed or open you
know public or private they talked about
you know what to call for witnesses in
terms of doctors to talk about
homosexuality but the key thing was
y'all ain't getting no personnel files
from the state department wow all right
so
uh memo is put out and that memo has
four elements that guides the state
department's interaction with the holy
subcommittee the congressional
subcommittee what are those four
elements element number one
dean ashland and james well would not be
involved in this whatsoever
they will only be informed of major
events and even then only when
necessary item two to the extent oh and
by the way humor sign will handle
everything he will be the single point
of contact the single spokesperson
because he was the guy actually running
it he's the guy who wrote the homophobic
memo that gave the history of the effort
right it's true webb was a carrier and
brought that memo over but you know he
had nothing to
you know he was doing a political job
that had nothing to do with the actual
effort right so the second thing is
the second element is to the extent that
uh humor sign needs advisement we're
creating this five uh person committee
and here's who those people are item
number three we will share some
statistics with you item number four you
will get no personnel files and that's
it web's gone
so think about this think about this
you're doing this job
a guy has to is running a committee a
senate committee to do something that he
doesn't want to do
and he asks you dude can you come talk
to me about this there's been this
schism between the executive branch
there's this problem about dealing with
um you know these personnel files let's
work this out together
he attends that one meeting and 70 years
later people say you initiated it you
ran it you were a homophobe
you know it's it's crazy
and it just keeps it keeps perpetuating
and they just cite each other i'm
reading an article
from nature magazine uh last year lately
yeah and it was uh oh well the critics
say this and critics say this that he
was uh influential and he could have he
could have uh been a part of that but i
don't think it makes him the right
choice this uh rolf danner an astronomer
at the jacob
what their everything they've said is
100 false
he had a meeting with truman he
regularly had meetings with truman he
supported the holy committee no he
didn't he attended a single meeting that
whole he requested that he attend and
then he sent a doctor a memo the
agreement was i would not be involved in
this at all then they say yeah but you
were there and you didn't speak out
really how do you know that
right
right my thing is an echo chamber so
this is the first time i'm speaking on
this except for this one cnn thing i did
and the reason why is i waited until
nasa made their decision
okay when they went out and they said
all these things let me tell you what
the worst part of this is right well let
before let me say this remember i
started off talking about that
confederate soldier and
you know what if this scenario now i
think to myself if that was me
and i had held that sort of animosity
for that stature all my life even when i
got the truth and that person didn't do
that i still wouldn't be eager to unhate
them right yeah it would take some time
right yeah so i tried to be
understanding sympathetic right and so
um i even suffered you know i even put
it in my book right so i was raised with
a mother and a sister and i had feminine
behaviors and characteristics so i was
called a [ __ ] all throughout my shot
and by the way you might not know this
but if you want to wear your hair as an
afro and your hair like mine you had to
wear it braided a lot right
so here i am with these bright eyes you
know
you know this braid i look like a little
girl right i act like a little girl so
you know i was getting the hell beaten
out of me by everybody so i'm like okay
let me be
you know let me under be understanding
here yeah but not only
what began to unfold next was something
that i did not expect
so what happened is another astronomer
said hey man i thought you and one of
these people had a good working
relationship because you were in the
same research collaboration yeah i
thought so too but it seems like they
hate me now after this article it's like
let me see if i can mediate this
then this person sends me a screenshot
where
one of the authors of that those
articles one of the two leaders says
ask hakeem why he left florida tech
and so i called him what what's that
about and he made it clear to me that
person
has made some very
horrible
allegations against you right and my
response is i don't care i live my life
i'm public everybody knows who i am what
i do
my life is
like you're you know making drugs yeah i
mean i'm not you know
so i completely ignored it until august
came
and i got a call from my dean my former
dean at florida tech his name is dr
hamad rasul and he says anybody is free
to contact him on this matter but he
told me he was having a conversation
with another uh of his colleagues from
another university and he says hey
wasn't hakeem a part of your faculty
like yeah well we were going to invite
him for this particular thing but one of
the young astronomer women spoke up and
said hey didn't you know certain certain
happen
and my ex-radio's a man a very you know
very principled man of honor type guy
right
he's like what no not hakeem you know
all right and so
so many members of the faculty so many
colleagues have told me this and then
when i got when it was announced
uh that i had gotten this faculty
position you know this um
named faculty position at at gmu one of
the authors had this twitter
rant
where they actually publicly used
certain words
right and then another astronomer sat
down with me i mean let me tell you the
three things they're saying man all of
them 100 true untrue
oh please added that all of them are 100
yeah uh because um
you know so here it is
you
[Music]
do this to the dead and now you're doing
this to the living and so you know i
don't
you know i don't feel the heat and the
reason why i don't feel the heat is
because
um you know i've diversified my life you
know i'm not just in the world of
physics and astronomy anymore right and
so you know you can't harm me through
that world is is everything but my
colleagues you know are like
they're outraged you know they're like
dude you should you know do this again i
don't do anything right but here's the
crazy thing about it
so at the end of that article i wrote in
january
and my article was a tl dr you know what
that means yeah too long too long you
didn't read right so it was a long
article at the end of that article i
lamented
on how these false allegations got so
far and i talked about the authors the
journalists who wrote the two articles
and i talked about their sources one of
which was the book towards stonewall
and so
it turns out that one of the the source
for the forbes article
is an astronomer
and
that person then went on their twitter
and said oh it's all an attack on me
all right now let's look at it
i didn't mention the person's name you
got to read all the way to the end of my
long article
to find that i say hey these two authors
and these two sources
are wrong the only person i named by
name is the author of that book toward
stonewall right
so you would have to go to read to the
end of my article then go back up to the
link at the top to that article
go read that article and then get to the
end of that article
to find the person's name
that is a weak hit piece
right if that's your intention
man you're not going about it right
right
and so then they claim the victim and
then go on an attack
whisper campaign against me
with the most horrific of allegations
and though in the nsbp
the women pointed this out to me these
allegations hakeem don't you realize
that this is what have gotten black men
killed in america historically
right these same people
that did the disinformation campaign on
web have been doing that
right
as well huh like a smear campaign
on
to the messenger who did the research
yeah innocent right and you know so but
but the thing is is that you know if you
read what they've written they also
attribute intention to me right or
trying to exonerate web no i'm not i'm
trying to find out what happened
um you know and things like that right
and oh here's another one
let me ask you brian have you ever uh
been working on something and a
colleague said hey read the paper by
oluseg and then you go read it and then
you you know you end up citing it in
your document yeah of course right yeah
do you ever cite the person who told you
no
no
no so here's what happened unless it's a
referee yeah right right this is a
referee right what happens is
the day after my article comes out
people start contacting me out the yin
yang okay
several web scholars
and people who worked at nasa with web
in the 60s
okay
and one of these web scholars pointed me
to the archive
where
i saw that that memo between humor sign
and web was because of this meeting all
right i didn't yet have these documents
from the national archive of the meeting
um but uh
um
so
this person also told me hey
don't tell anyone that uh
i gave you this
because
they tried to pressure me in the past
and i could find no evidence to support
that i don't want them on my back again
so what do they do when they write their
article about the straights you know or
hit or save us that's right yeah they
say well look at what hakeem did
we tweeted
the archive location and then he
wouldn't change his article and didn't
cite us for telling
him what a primary
resource is i'm like you should only
do it from primary resource and i didn't
get it from you anyway i got it from
this other person right um
and so it's really crazy and if you look
you know and so you know it's so insane
that they you know
create a lot of narratives that are
false
for what purpose is it
to drive to discover the truth and
uncover the truth about the situation
because i'm thinking whoo you know the
confederate statue guy actually wasn't a
confederate yeah and not only that we
got a lot of evidence that they did
great stuff right
to me which meant
it's a tragedy to falsely accuse anyone
it's several organ two orders of
magnitude worse if they're a good person
doing good things for humans
right and so that's what i was arguing
so the main argument i think against
webb
not against web but for web so the first
thing about web is so this i got to give
you one last thing and this is about
webb's um
you know what about him in bureaucracy
because
here's the thing
webb had a hero so they write about um
here's what they say
i'm trying to find it where he talks
they talk about uh
webb and his nerdiness around
um
i didn't i didn't have it marked anyway
the point is is that you know if you if
you read powering apollo you will see
that they mentioned how webb read
everything he could about administration
and bureaucracy and learn you know you
read the giants right so just like
someone could ask me oh who's your
favorite physicist ever
webb had a favorite
giant thinker of
administration
it was a woman who in the early 20th
century
lived in a same sex relationship openly
mary parker follett and every chance he
got webb was lauding mary parker
followed now one thing about being a
member of
one of the you know lower cl rungs of
the hierarchy ladder you know
is
you know you could have straight-up
races that love lebron right because you
know you fit in certain roles but one
role that a person who has an ism never
gives you know never gives
is
intellectual power right that is not you
know not them not in a worship right
yeah they have open animosity and
timothy for right yeah exactly so but
here's the other thing right at the
exact same time you know when webb was
in the but you know just as they were
doing that in in the state department as
that was beginning red was running his
own agency the budget bureau of budget
shouldn't he have been doing that there
if he was doing it in state right
wouldn't he have
you know so so anyway there's so much to
it so so i know that was just like a bud
but i have another article uh to fill
all the holes and show the reality of it
in its full context and it is a complete
unnecessary
wrong word that has been done
substantiated by an independent you know
nasa research committee that that also
looked into this uh his his
you know whether or not it could be
problematic or whether or not
that actually so so here's the other
thing about that
uh another thing that's funny about how
if you look at those articles especially
the the first ones they're like hey but
he's not even a historian don't listen
to him it was a real story here's what
they said but then you go out as an
astronomer and do this campaign right
like listen to me about history i'm a
non-historian don't listen to that
non-historian
um and but here's the thing i didn't do
it alone i did it with a guy getting a
phd
i did it with nasa historians archivists
and journalists i mean not journalists
librarians and they say this to me
they're like hakeem we're so glad you're
involved in this we don't want to be
publicly recognized because we see this
like the moon landing right there's
nothing we can do to convince the uh
conspiracy nuts that uh you know it's
real uh and if we put our names on it's
gonna look like an inside cleaning job
or whatever so it's on you so what i did
is i waited um you know more than a year
to after i left nasa so it's clear that
it's me and not nasa who's doing this uh
you know i wrote the entire thing myself
it's independently on medium yeah i'll
have a link to that
um well you know it takes a tremendous
amount of courage and that's not really
surprising to me but basically i know it
was a no-win yeah yeah right i mean the
right thing to do so you know
and you gave the the right analogy i
mean i'm jewish if i had if there was
some you know uh test you know something
that was testimony to uh some some you
know nazi or something like i'm not
comparing the two but but still to think
about that uh i would have certainly a
lot of misguided feelings if it turned
out that i was also a member you know if
i was in charge of at least revealing or
didn't reveal something true that was
inconvenient or uncomfortable and then
later uh you know condemned for doing
that because the narrative that people
want to believe um anyway we we talked a
lot about this almost
let me say one last thing yeah
overwhelmingly the response from the
community has been positive this small
group of people are savvy smart media
savvy they did what they did and drove a
you know a large movement but uh within
physics and astronomy
people were like great job
yeah
yeah yeah no no that's true and then of
course the telescope was not renamed it
was it was discussed and uh and you know
after a thorough investigation by nasa
they decided not to do it it has now
been renamed but you know and you'll
still see these uh you know kind of
contentions out there and they're always
you know kind of uncontested necessarily
and don't have the thoroughness of
research that you have and and you know
that that that's their prerogative that
people have other things they want to do
with their life i wonder if the family
of james webb has been in touch with you
or absolutely we're close now in fact
they uh there was going to be an event
when uh the first date december 15th
well not the first date but you know
right december 15th and so they wrote to
me they were like yeah man you know nasa
gave us a couple of tickets to attend
this event at goddard and we asked him
for a third ticket for you to come with
us um we're we're family now in a way
right but so many people reach out to me
not just the webb family they're like
why would you do this dude you know
you know
who are you i'm like look to be honest
with you
i got nothing in it i could care less
about webb what i care about is the fact
that people
are looking at you know i imagine what
it would be like if uh you know david
duke and every day i got to hear that
the david duke observers are they you
know that would drive me crazy right so
i knew that members of the community
were feeling some way every time they
had to hear this name you know and so i
was gonna do one thing or the other like
to be honest with you you know i i know
that i don't know until i know but if i
had a bias going in it was assumption
that it was real it was true yeah yeah
right and i was gonna be like i've shown
you what he did now get him out of here
you know seems plausible right yeah what
happened what i discovered was the
opposite of that and what what am i
going to do i'm going to be like okay
this is great right because now we no
longer have this one way or the other
we're getting rid of the problem right
yeah yeah and it's not you know and so
it it what what
i mean to me man
really you know someone said this on on
twitter uh
it's
it's really like professional misconduct
in a way to incite the community around
the lie and then to you know do a
whisper smear campaign i can't really
affect people yeah you know and and yeah
it's it's no i always you know i would
say when
there's internecine fighting you know
between say with jews fighting against
jews i always say like we have enough
problems with the rest of the world like
hating on us why why do we have to hate
on each other right and nobody cares
really right like one of the things that
i i saw for example you know there was
two black scholars
um
michael eric dyson and um what's the
dude's name cornel west i don't know
what yeah they had he wrote these long
essays attacking each other and i'm like
dude nobody cares y'all care but you
know it's kind of like
you know i'm gonna write a long essay
and put it out to the public so
everybody can be a part of it it may be
tweeted yes i may tweet it i don't know
yeah nobody cares right so i'm not you
know
i'm just continuing on my path doing
what i do right i also look at these
people you know in the black community
in the in the homosexual community
lesbian gay bisexual however you want to
call it and i and i find you know i do a
lot of interviews it happens to be i
have a lot of african i think i've had
more african-american scientists on this
podcast than any podcast i'm aware of
i'm just and i'm not like proud of it
i'm not saying oh pat me on the back i'm
such a good white ally i think that's
demeaning actually i think you know the
day you need me as an ally you know like
you're doing just fine you know and and
i do need you as an ally right i'm like
but i'm not supporting you because i'm
not your ally because you're black i'm
your ally because you're you're an
impressive individual you're a human
being has accomplished a tremendous
amount who has merit who has uh who has
courage and those are the rarest
qualities that came and i do feel like
you know it's it's funny because i was
like walking around my son on a walk
we'd take a walk with one of my kids
and i was like i'm talking to a guy
today and his name's hakeem
what do you think that means and he's
like let me think about that does it
mean smart and i said
let me think about it why would it mean
smart and he goes because in hebrew the
word
means
wise man
that is great he didn't say oh he's
muslim or he's arab no he just said he's
a wise man i thought that was cool and
that's what i want to be associated with
so yeah what i i use i call it keating's
razor you know about occam's razor so
i'll put out these you know i'll have
interviews with people that are
controversial about people on the right
on the left and then i'll have
interviews with p and i'll get
condemnation when i have someone on the
right on but then i'll have an interview
with a lesbian you know a bisexual gay
transgender queer you know black woman
say yeah you know that's happened
multiple times and there'll be no love
there'll be no like oh thank you for
being whatever they knew and i'm just
like how come you give me so much crap
you know when i have on something you
don't like and you associate guilt by
association when i have on somebody who
is in a community that you're treasuring
that you're wanting to support you show
me no love i mean i don't so now i don't
let that go to my head anymore i don't
let the criticism go to my
planers man i mean you know the thing
you know people there's a variety you
know i i of course we i rode a plane in
1999 when i was in silicon valley to um
heathrow from san francisco yeah i was
sitting next to an accountant from for
johnson johnson and this man
found accounting fascinating and he
talked to me about it and found
astronomy astrophysics what i was doing
not interesting at all yeah boring
that's how i found account is
funny discussion right and i'm like it's
that's such an interesting thing that
humans are like that you know we have a
variety and so you know i realized that
and so like for me for example you know
i'm of the type of you know it's hard to
find me complaining you know i'm like
let's take action on this i'm not gonna
you know i just find you know
that uh
you know so so the point is that we're
in a a um
situation
now
where people
are empowered to speak out they have a
voice maybe for the first time yeah and
i think that
when you get a voice
you know well the first thing i think
that there shouldn't be a single
approach to any problem
all right yeah so you know there's a
reason why you have the good cop back
you know and things like that right
exactly so i think that having a variety
of approaches approaches is the definite
thing that you should do
uh
but
if you are going to
[Music]
um
yeah i don't know man it's just
frustrating to me yeah when you know i i
feel like people have the best of
intentions
and
you know they're they want to do right
but then sometimes you know you find
yourself doing the wrong even though you
really want to do right you know yeah i
mean i i just i don't yeah my rule is i
don't judge people on their intentions i
judge them based on their actions yeah
and you know you can have good
intentions all you like but right but if
you're not you know if you're not really
kind of creating good and i'm a
behaviorist i believe you know your
actions speak louder than your words and
his words are cheap and especially in
arabic social media it's like you can't
get amplified
i mean remember mark twain said in 1890s
you know the a lie can make it around
the world you know
before a truth even gets its pants on
and there's another statement which is a
lie don't live long right
yeah there's a parable in in judaism
where where a man slanders a rabbi
there's a name for it and it's one of
the greatest sins there is called la
shanhara
slander's a rabbi and then he feels bad
about it but slander he's telling the
truth he's not lying about the rabbi
he's just he's telling a rumor gossip
and then he goes to the rabbi and he
says i feel so bad about it how can i
make amends and the rabbi says very
simple go get a feather pillow guy's
like what the heck all right i'll get a
feather pill he goes um uh here's your
feather pillow what am i done no uh go
ahead and cut it open oh all right i'll
cut it open so he cuts it open and the
feathers start blowing away and and the
rabbi says okay you're almost done now
just go out and get all the feathers
back
and the point being it's like you can't
like i always say to my you know words
are like toothpaste you know once you
use it you can't take it back yeah so
you know for me this this whole episode
it's depressing it's demoralizing in a
certain way it's also hopeful because
people like you do exist that can kind
of blow the whistle for truth and set
the record straight even when you start
off maybe not even inclined to take that
attack from the very beginning
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
you